hundreds of years ago sailors thought
octopi were sea monsters called devil
fish capable of dragging down ships we
know they're not devil fish but we still
don't know everything about them
including where they'll turn up next
we've created a Plexiglas Wonderland
just so you can observe how amazing this
creature really is the octopus imagine
that you're an octopus like this cyanea
here your body has no bones none and
what that means is that you'd be able to
go almost anywhere you want to even if
you happen to be a very large octopus
600-pounder say you'd be able to squeeze
yourself down so far you could pass
through a passageway no larger than a
quarter since you don't have air
bladders or gas pockets that would crush
or implode at great depths you can live
at the very very bottom of the ocean
where there's 15,000 pounds of pressure
per square inch a human being exposed to
that kind of pressure would implode in a
split second can you imagine how much
fun it would be to be an octopus you
could go anywhere you want slide under a
door get into any room you'd have a body
unlike any other on earth if you get
hungry you could use one of your 240
suction cups to grab a meal no matter
how many yoga classes a human takes
he'll never be this flexible